[Music]
Pookie is a refugee for years he's been
living in a camp near Cape Town but he
has to keep much of his private life to
himself
that's because Pookie is gay in fact
that's why he left some bar boy when I
was 18 years when they post the Acacia
CD when we were coming from India from
the path with my friend when we in track
they asked her that what is happening a
kiss what is happening and you saying
then my friend is born all my kids and I
said then after that the arrest ask them
they torture us they put the how I ate
inside the water so that when they are
pitching us you must not cry loudly with
some people they must not he understand
then my friend he passed away because to
just stay close to two weeks then my
friend is just a to the side
the police let pokey go to this day he's
not sure why cookie says he led a
sheltered life as a child his father was
a soldier book he tells us his life
story including details of how and why
he became a prostitute working streets
like this one there was a six-week they
it was not easy at that time this church
in I never even saw my mom or do you -
PA - Haven my father it was a little
strange and to me panicky which is I was
supposed to do it through the situation
cause I was not wiki real I was
desperate for him and one of Pookie's
clients infected him with HIV he stopped
working as a prostitute about a year ago
there are very few support networks for
gay refugees in South Africa but an
organization called possib tries to help
where it can pass up provides counseling
and other services they also help new
refugees find a place to live yeah I
think that facing a lot of challenge
especially with documentation issue
because when they arrived South Africa
festered in to apply for asylum and many
of them decided to get the refugee
status also after that there is the
issue of a lot of discrimination of
Africa even in connection of funding
jobs opportunities South Africa because
once they apply for position and if they
discover that the LGBT I didn't want to
take them
Robina is also looking for work she came
to South Africa from Uganda she doesn't
want to show us her face she's afraid of
the authorities
Robina says it was difficult to leave
her homeland but she had no other choice
yeah this is my album this is me I was
playing with national team in Uganda
they way I left in my country because
I'm an LGBTI member then that is a loss
which is they didn't allow they gives it
is really in my country gays and
lesbians who are convicted under sexual
preference laws in Uganda face prison
sentences of at least 14 years
Robina knew she was breaking the law and
lived in constant fear that she'd be
arrested
she describes the situation that forced
her to leave Uganda when I was in Uganda
I was dating the lady the lady through
this they do talk one of the government
e-government member Robin and I stood
South Africa has one of the most liberal
sexual preference laws in the world but
those laws don't provide much protection
for her the day I was it was my first
time to walk around by the station then
I met the guy they asked me why are you
wearing like a guy are you a you tomboy
I didn't I didn't reply them then they
start to hold me and to rape me it was
so painful but I never put the police
sometimes Robina plays football with
other refugees
none of the men know that she's a
lesbian if they found out it could have
serious consequences for her
bias against gays and lesbians is
spreading in South Africa fundamentalist
Christian groups including some based in
the US are speaking out against what
they see as a violation of God's law the
Christian Right is now looking to Africa
as a place where they can mobilize
support for their own causes mobilize
support for their pro-family politics
which are explicitly homophobic Nigeria
recently toughened its laws on sexual
preference so a manual Okoye a packed up
and left for Cape Town and he did it
just in time a number of his friends
were later arrested a man while still
hasn't found a place to live he doesn't
have a job so he has no money he has to
resort to begging to get by Cape Town is
a very beautiful city but as I'm sitting
I'm sitting with nothing
the whole people that I meet want to
have sex with me before they have me and
my family want me to join in drugs so
that I can be able to make em make a
living in this town but I said no that I
don't I don't need that so as you are
seeing me I am left with nothing
this is not the kind of life that a man
well expected when he arrived here but
he says it's better than being in prison
many African gays and lesbians come to
South Africa to escape discrimination
but they often find that the rainbow
nation fails to live up to its
reputation as a safe haven
[Music]